while a bug's life was a success it
didn't quite bring in the numbers that
Toy Story did and even the critical
reaction to it seemed to be kind of
mixed so Pixar went back to the drawing
board with Toy Story 2 I don't think
people really knew what to expect with
this I mean it's a sequel to a film they
really really liked and seeing how this
was a new production studio we didn't
know could they do sequels could they do
follow-ups well a lot of sequels are
usually not as good as the first one so
people are kind of nervous but at the
same time they were excited to see their
favorite characters again and from my
standpoint Toy Story 2 was not only as
good as the original I think it's even
better ok what's the story Woody and
Buzz are back again but this time woody
is in a bit of a predicament a garage
sale is going on and sadly one of the
older toys is being sold off when he
goes in to save them but inevitably gets
stolen by a nasty toy store owner
because we figure out that woody is
actually a very rare toy in fact he used
to actually be part of a TV show that's
right
Woody's a collector's item and he's not
the only one he also comes across a
cowgirl named Jesse a horse named
bullseye and a miner named the
prospector the race is on for the rest
of Woody's friends to go out and save
him but it seems like woody may have
second thoughts about returning back
home because he knows that eventually he
has to face the inevitable that Andy
will grow up and someday forget about
him he has another choice where he can
be taken to a museum where he can be
enjoyed by children forever people would
come from all over the world just to see
that he exists and it's great riding
like this that once again makes Toy
Story great yes there is kind of a
villain in this movie with the toy store
owner and yes even another one that's
eventually revealed but again their
motivations are understandable it's just
the fact that they want to force their
point of views on other people that
ultimately make them kind of bad guys
but the dilemma that woody has to go
through is actually a good dilemma in
fact you're kind of siding with him
going to the museum heck some of these
toys even have backstories Jesse's
backstory is one of the emotional
highlights of the entire film but to
balance it
now she's not just a sad
stick-in-the-mud she's a very fun active
character as well in fact all the new
characters are we have a mrs. Potato
Head the evil Emperor Zurg another Buzz
Lightyear that goes through the exact
same motions as the first one and look
even Barbie makes an appearance in this
how cool is that that the marketing team
that brought us Barbie something so
controlled and so protective of their
identity actually allowed them to kind
of make fun of their brand as I said
before I'm not a huge Randy Newman fan
but you know what the song in here is a
good song probably one of his best in
fact I'll admit it's very well done the
CG on the people has gotten better too I
mean true they don't look like actual
people but the textures are better and
yeah you know a lot of the facial
expressions seem to work pretty well the
dramatic moments are very strong they're
never out of place they're very
emotionally satisfying and you relate
with every single aspect of it you
relate with dealing with the inevitable
what will ultimately happen in the end
what should you do what's the better
thing for yourself and for others
what's the selfish thing what's the
unselfish thing all this stuff plays in
and it's very very smart and very very
well done just when you think something
like Toy Story couldn't possibly get any
better they surprised us with this very
well told well written well developed
interesting continuation of a story not
a rehash it's clever it's funny it's
dramatic it's visually interesting it's
musically interesting the characters are
wonderful I've gone on about it long
enough see it if you haven't already
you